bueno en primer lugar por la ubicación
histórica que han tenido afganistán en
el corazón de asia central en gracia
central y medio oriente siempre ha sido
una ruta de paso el comercio de la red
de infraestructura de la región y
siempre una región conflictiva
ingobernable y inaccesible en términos
geográficos nosotros de las
características y casi 30 a 40 años de
inestabilidad política desde la invasión
soviética del 79 para acá después una
guerra civil de 15 años preocupación
estadounidense ha sido punto neurálgico
y conflictivo de la región ahora
patricia de países como ustedes bien lo
hacía como rusia irán o china que ya
tienen alguna especie de nexo con el
talibán cuáles son los intereses de
estas naciones en afganistán yo creo que
el principal interés se ha hablado mucho
y yo creo que más bien desde posición
ideológica yo creo que el principal
interés de todas las naciones de la
región es la estabilidad es el orden la
estabilidad y que va a afganistán no se
convierta de ahora en más en el
principal santuario del terrorismo del
mundo
en su totalidad sido tomado por un grupo
fundamentalista que históricamente ha
refugiado a los terroristas esto le
preocupa china esto le preocupa a rusia
los intereses económicos de estos países
son relativamente escasos más bien
incluso la india también tendríamos que
sumar e irán más bien el interés
principal de todos estos países
potencias regionales es el orden la
estabilidad y que afganistán en que en
afganistán a partir de ahora no prospere
masivamente el botín si es que
precisamente usted ya lo mencionaba y
frente a este escenario diferente al
temor de que afganistán se convierta
entonces en un refugio para el
terrorismo será al país un escenario de
división entre las potencias
occidentales y naciones como china o
rusia y otras yo creo que es una pena y
probablemente quede en una vereda de los
eeuu con esta retirada y esta ocupación
de 20 años facilidad en el marco del
conflicto con china no sobre todo quede
como en una verdad quizá china
supuestamente sosteniendo al talibán con
rusia y con otros aliados y los eeuu
esto es una visión realmente que va a
conducir a que la situación solamente
empeore porque es imposible imaginar que
afganistán en algún momento cercano se
estabilice sin la cooperación de eeuu
china rusia india y otras potencias
regionales y que es probable es probable
que esto que decís suceda pero sería una
pena porque eso le daría a empeorar la
situación en afganistán